quoiqu'elle sinon bonjour à tous ici du
lot lire mathias et je vous souhaite la
bienvenue à kapatakan bienvenue à cette
toute première chronique de l'année donc
ce tout premier portage
permettez moi de vous souhaiter donc
pour la nouvelle année évidemment de la
santé mais aussi beaucoup de découvertes
et beaucoup d'authenticité
donc pour l'année à venir
pour pour la chronique pendant que pour
ma première chronique de 2022 j'avais
envie de parler de souhaits de l'espoir
que j'ai pour la prochaine année
mais d'abord permettez-moi de revenir
rapidement sur donc une nouvelle qui est
sorti à la fin de l'année 2000 21 qui
est celle de la personnalité de l'année
donc la presse canadienne à chaque année
identifie donc une personnalité pour
l'année donc l'année en cours et et 2021
et la personnalité retenue a été celle
des enfants dont qui ont fréquenté les
pensionnats évidemment 2021 ça a été une
année de deuil je pense d'auteuil pour
les autochtone aussi de deuil collectif
pour les canadiens et canadiennes et ça
a été une occasion de se recueillir
ensemble et peut-être de se questionner
en tant que collectivité sur qu'est ce
qui s'est passé dans le passé et les
impacts que ça peut avoir encore
aujourd'hui sur les autochtones
donc on
on me dédier cette personnalité de
l'année aux jeunes qui ont fréquenté des
pensionnaires et moyens pour 2022
j'avoue j'avais aussi envie de parler de
jeunesse mais un la jeunesse dans
l'espoir parce qu'en fait je le vois le
depuis en fait 2021 était quand même une
année où est ce que j'ai vu des
changements positifs et j'espère que ça
continuera 2022 et je vois que la
jeunesse autochtone elle prend de plus
en plus de place et pour moi mais aussi
rempli d'espoir et pour ma première
chronique mais j'avais envie de vous
parler de trois jeunes de trois jeunes
autochtones qui pour moi sont à
surveiller pour 2022 donc permettez moi
de commencer là la première personne
dont j'ai envie de vous parler c'est
d'une artiste de ma communauté nom d'une
jeune peco gemmenich qu il s'agit de
raphaël langevin
raphaël c'est une jeune entrepreneur qui
a fondé
donc la compagnie qui s'appelle match
échoue création raphaël effet des
vêtements et fait des bijoux et des
accessoires
c'est une jeune qui est tellement allumé
m impressionne tellement j'ai eu
l'occasion de fréquenter à quelques
reprises au courant de l'année 2021 et
j'ai hâte de la revoir en 2012 je trouve
que c'est une jeune fille tellement en
jouer une jeune mère de famille au début
de la vingtaine qui s'est dit qu'il
avait envie de réaliser son rêve de se
partir son entreprise de partager sa
culture de partager son art de partager
son artisanat et il réussit très bien
jusqu'à maintenant en 2021 et le
participer à un concours qui s'appelle
le pas au pitch et l'état rick vais donc
c'est un concours qui se passe à la
grandeur du canada auprès du polio
nation elle est arrivé 15e sur 1600
entrepreneurs qui ont participé au
concours je pense qu'on peut lui donner
une bonne mine applaudissements chapeau
a fait elle plus impressionnantes qu'il
aura 22 ans je pense là ils sont déjà
rendus là donc j'ai beaucoup d'espoir
donc une jeune femme à surveiller au
courant de l'année 2022 est évidemment
une artiste à suivre je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui est très inspirant autant
du point de vérité que du point de vue
personnel
la deuxième personne dont j'avais envie
de vous parler c'est samuel un vieux sam
entre ville qui a été nommé il en
décembre 2021
conseiller principal relations avec les
premiers peuples à l'université de
montréal donc son rôle à samuel ce sera
d'accompagner l'université de
conseillers l'université dans le rôle
qu'elles jouent auprès des étudiants
autochtones qui fréquentent
l'établissement est ce que je trouve
vraiment impressionnant dans cette
nomination doit c'est le fait de samuel
il est tout jeune je pense qu'on a à peu
près le même âge que l'on est dans la me
21 et je salue vraiment cette nomination
là parce que samuel clairement depuis je
vais pas parler pour lui mais je pense
pas qu'il ait 15 et 20 ans d'expérience
dans le bien si tu seigneur mais il a
clairement une expérience dans la
réalité que vivent les étudiants
autochtones au sein d'un établissement
universitaire et c'est ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir apporter et ça je salue ce genre
de décisions des organisations qui
disent mais nous on va peut-être les
sites côté
l'expérience professionnelle mais
vraiment mettre de l'avant l'expérience
de l'humain parce que je pense qu'il
veut clairement quelque chose à porter
c'est un jeune qui chevron qui est super
engagé dans sa communauté dans la
communauté urbaine entre autres à
montréal et dans les communautés donc
dans sa communauté également et j'ai
juste hâte de voir qu'est ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir mettre en place au cours de la
prochaine année je pense que le milieu
universitaire
est en train de se renouveler par
rapport à ce qui concerne les jeunes
autochtones mais je pense que des
personnalités des jeunes comme samuel
vont clairement pouvoir faire une
différence et à mener des actions encore
plus loin là donc la troisième personne
dont j'ai envie de vous parler c'est
d'une bonne amie à moi en fait c'est de
gabriel vachon le rhin qui en décembre
dernier a été nommée vice présidente de
femmes autochtones du québec donc encore
loin une jeune moins de 30 ans qui
accède à un poste comme ça dans une
organisation
puis j'espère que
ça va porter peu près de l'espoir ça
vous inspirer d'autres jeunes d'autres
jeunes femmes aussi à s'impliquer dans
des organisations parce que c'est pas
toujours évident de trouver sa place et
de se dire que on a notre place et un
rôle à jouer dans des organisations
comme celles là que ce soit ferme
autochtones du québec ou des
organisations autochtones
il faut de plus en plus de jeunes qui
font de plus en plus de profils
différents pour avoir une meilleure idée
de des différentes réalités qui existent
et je pense qu'il y ait brillé elle même
si c'est une excellente porte parole
pour ça c'est une jeune inoue les super
dynamique je trouve qu'ils aient est
hélas pour l'avoir entendu à plusieurs
reprises de gabriel et le ce discours
rassemblant je pense que c'est ce dont
j'ai besoin en 2022 d'espoir de sentir
ensemble de sentir que comme qu'on est
content qu'on dit une espèce de force
collective je pense donc je pense que
c'est ces trois jeunes le sont sont des
exemples de de l'espoir que j'ai pour la
jeunesse autochtone je pense qu'ils sont
des modèles en devenir ils le sont déjà
ils le seront certainement cours des
prochaines années évidemment j'aurais pu
parler de plein de personnes mais
j'avais envie de faire une chronique à
un peu plus concise commun est
clairement ce sont des jeunes que je
vous invite à suivre au cours de l'année
2022 est aussi mais je vous invite à
vous intéresser aux jeunes autochtones
qui gravite peut-être dans vos
supérieurs dans votre entourage autour
de vous puis à s'intéresser à eur puis
évidemment à les encourager à persévérer
a continué puis surtout à leur donner
des opportunités de parler de
s'impliquer de faire valoir
les personnes qui sont puis qu'ils
puissent mais apporter leur contribution
dans les milieux où elle s'implique donc
c'est ce que je me souhaite pour 2022 et
sur ce je vous souhaite à vous encore
une excellente année 2032 et je vous dis
à bientôt pour un reportage non